so when I'm card counting I'm playing
perfect basic strategy give the accurate
track of the running cow converting that
running count into a true account based
on the number of decks remaining and
then sizing my bet proportionately based
on the truth down
what makes blackjack different from all
the other games is that it's based on
dependent events which means that the
past actually affects the probability
what's going to happen next
now the card counting system that I
recommend is called high-low count
system we have the high cards 10 Jack
Queen King and ace and these are good
for the player but they have a count
value of -1 each because as high cards
are depleted from the game player
advantage up goes down the next group of
cards is the low cards 2 3 4 5 and 6 and
these cards are good for the dealer
so naturally these are going to each
have a count value of +1 because as
these low cards are depleted that means
there's fear of them that can hurt you
in future play and a third and final
group of cards is a neutral cards 7 8 9
and these cards don't have a count value
at all because they don't favor the
house or the player if we're to look at
these Street cards the count of these is
the minus 1 we have two hikers and one
load cards for these three cards they
have a count of +2 we have two low cards
which each have a count value plus 1 and
the neutral card has no count value
[Music]
now what most people would do once they
learn to hide load count values is to
adjust the count one by one so for
example they would think minus 1 plus 1
minus 1 plus 1 minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
plus 1 and so the net of all that work
would be minus 2 so that required
adjusting to cow big times but if you
use a technique called meaningful pairs
you're going to reduce your workload and
improve your speed dramatically so
looking at this first hand we have a
cancel I love another high-low
combination another cancel so no work
required here we're gonna have two high
cards so we're gonna go -2 and once
again another cancel and a neutral card
doesn't mean anything with regard to get
out so using the pair's we only have to
adjust to count one time
now once the hands are actually played
out and players are hitting and doubling
down we will count them one at a time so
we're at minus 2 you take a hit
that brings us to minus 1 another hit
minus 2 minus 3 back 2 minus 2 and we
end around at minus 3 so the running
count is very important there's one more
step you need to convert that running
cow into what we call the true count so
this right here is about one deck of
cards the true count is simply the
running count divided by the number of
decks remaining rounded to the nearest
half deck so for example if you have a
running count of +9 and there's 4 and
1/2 decks remaining while 9 over 4 and
1/2 gives
true count of plus two and as true count
increases player advantage increases so
the general idea is to bet little or
nothing when you don't have the
advantage
and then that proportionately more as
your advantage increases so as far as
how we would size our bets we would bet
true count minus one better use so for
example if you are had to have a betting
unit of $25.00 and the true count is
plus 2 2 minus 1 is 1 so you should bet
$25 so let's say the running count is
plus 20 as you can see we have one deck
that has come out even if there's five
decks remaining so that gives us a true
count of 20 divided by 5 decks remaining
true count of plus 4 we're going to
subtract 1 to get the optimal bet of 3
units and let's use a betting unit of
$100 so runny count 20 so we're gonna
play this out now we have to play basic
strategy as we're keeping track of
account now the count has moved down a
bit to plus 17 so we have a plus 17
count divided by about four and a half
two decks remaining so we're still at
about a true can of plus four so we can
keep the same bet
reni count has increased to 23 so 23
with four decks remaining about gives us
a true count of +6 so how much should we
bet well five units so now you get a
sense of everything that you have to do
you have to play perfect basic strategy
keep track of the running count convert
that into the proper troop count based
on index remaining and then hopefully
have enough leeway to be able to
interact with other players and pay
attention to what's going on